hi I'm Sophie she lacy with
Entertainment Tonight with sad news
today coming out of Los Angeles Tom
Petty went in cardiac arrest on Sunday
night this according to TMZ the singer
was rushed to the hospital after being
found unconscious according to the
outlet he was placed on life support but
has since been taken off petit has been
known as a cultural icon who transcended
the music industry and pop culture he's
known for hits like American Girl free
fallin won't back down and so so many
more the singer had just wrapped up his
40th anniversary tour with the
Heartbreakers last Monday at the
Hollywood Bowl on a personal note I was
at that show in the audience and he
seemed so happy upbeat proud very
energetic was light hearted and telling
lots of great stories about the history
of the band I actually shot this sweet
moment at the very end of the show
I want to thank all of you for coming
out tonight
[Applause]
we love you dearly I want to thank you
for 40 years of a really great time
[Applause]
[Music]
you